لم يتم رفع الجسر هنا
طالما يمكنهم تذكره ولكن
لم يتم غزو مدينة ميكاليف الساحلية الهادئة ، من المحتمل أن
يكون كلاك كلاك تبادلًا مع
المظليين الروس الذين قيل لنا إنهم
هبطوا
بالقرب من السكان المحليين يكافحون من أجل مواكبة
عالمهم  هنا ينهار والجنود
يثيرون الخوف هنا حيث قام الجنود بإلقاء المخربين الروس مثل
هذين المشتبه بهم أرضًا
ثم تنطلق صفارات الإنذار
[موسيقى
] ويعود إلى الطابق السفلي
للأمهات والقطط
هنا ضجيج ما ستفعله روسيا
بهذه البلدات  باسم
القهر والمكاسب الجيوسياسية ،
تحاول الشرطة إطفاء الأنوار على ما
يبدو في الأعمال التجارية التي أغلقت في
عجلة من أمرها ،
استمرت الحياة عالقة بين الأمل في أن هذا لم يدم طويلاً والتساؤل عما إذا كان
يمكن أن يستمر إلى الأبد
وراء كل ذلك في الشوارع الفارغة.
قد يتم التجاوز
وما إذا كان كل انفجار ضخم
سيكون الضربة الحاسمة التي تسمح
لقوات بوتين بالدخول
[موسيقى] ،
استمر القصف ،
وفي صباح اليوم التالي رأينا أين  لقد أصابته
، من المحتمل أن صاروخًا دمر هذه
الدبابات الأوكرانية ، لكن لم يبقَ أحد يشعر
بالكسر
كيف تشعر أنك بحالة
جيدة جدًا ، نعم ،
لقد حاولوا القدوم إلى المدينة ، لكنني
أرى أبي يخبرنا
أنه يقول إن الروس حاولوا
القدوم الليلة الماضية لكن المدينة  نيكولايف
تغلب
عليهم ويمكنك أن ترى ما يبدو
هنا
قائلاً انظر حولك هنا ، أسأل
كيف تشعر أنك تعيش هنا وأنت تنظر إلى
كل هذا ، هذا هو المكان الذي تعيش فيه تمامًا ،
إنها تبدو وكأنها تنظر إلى هذه
النوافذ التي تهب  حسنًا ،
حسنًا ، كلمات الوزراء الروس
الذين كانوا يقولون إنهم
لن يضربوا البنية التحتية المدنية
هنا يعيدها مرة أخرى لي قائلاً
انظروا إلى هذا
يقولون إنهم لا يصيبون
البنية التحتية المدنية ، انظروا إلى هذا
الضرر هنا
ربما تكون صواريخ بوتين قد تحطمت الزجاج
ولكن لم تخفف من حدة الغضب هنا
أثناء قيامهم بالتقييم ، عليك أن تسأل
نفسك لماذا اعتقدت موسكو أن هذه
البلدات ستحتل بكل سرور
وهدف روسيا النهائي هو
تيمبي  rs هنا
تم إراقة الدماء ولكن على الرغم
من القوة النارية الهائلة لروسيا ، إلا أنهم
لم يمروا